"THE FIVE"
"THE FIVE."
>> THE HOUSE JUDICIARY ON THE
JUDICIARY IS INTRODUCING TWO
ARTICLES OF IMPEACHMENT CHARGING
THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES, DONALD J. TRUMP,
WITH COMMITTING HIGH CRIMES AND
MISDEMEANORS.
THE FIRST ARTICLE IS FOR ABUSE
OF POWER.
THIS GIVES RISE TO THE SECOND
ARTICLE OF IMPEACHMENT FOR
OBSTRUCTION OF CONGRESS.
>> Greg: NOT TO.
TO ACCUSATIONS THAT ARE SO VAGUE
THEY CAN MEAN ANYTHING AND
NOTHING WHICH IS THE PLANTS.
AFTER ALL, WHEN THERE IS NO
CRIME, YOU'VE GOT TO LEAVE IT TO
THE IMAGINATION AND BOY IS THIS
OPEN TO INTERPRETATION.
IT'S LIKE AN ACT FOR THE BLIND
WHICH SUITS THE MEDIA PERFECTLY.
REMEMBER HOW THIS PROCESS WAS
REVERSE ENGINEERED.
IT WASN'T HERE'S THE CRIME,
LET'S IMPEACH.
IT WAS LESS IMPEACH AND HOPE WE
FIND A CRIME.
IF IT'S THE HOLIDAY REBOOT OF
LET'S PASS THE BILL TO SEE
WHAT'S IN IT AND WHAT A FLOP,
WORSE THAN ANGRY BIRDS TWO.
WE KNEW IT AND YET WE HAD TO
CARRY THE FOREST DESPITE IT
FEATURING CLOUDS WHO JOKED ABOUT
BARON AND EDITED CLIPS OF TRON.
WHILE THE PRICE TORTURED VIEWERS
BY PRETENDING IT MATTERED, ONE
QUESTION REMAINED.
WHY DIDN'T THE REPUBLICANS BOLT?
AFTER ALL, WE KNEW IT WAS A
STUPID SKIT DESIGNED TO MAKE
THEM FEEL GOOD SINCE THEY ARE
IMMUNE TO FEELING STUPID.
THE REST OF US ARE LEFT WITH
WHAT COPS CALLED THE MESS
MEETING WHEN THIEVES BREAK INTO
A HOUSE AND FIND NOTHING, THE
ONLY THING LEFT TO DO IS TRASH
THE PLACE.
HENCE THE ABUSE OF POWER WHICH
ANYONE CAN NOW USE ON THE DEMS
AND THEY SHOULD.
WHEN YOU MOVE FORWARD WITH A
THREE YEAR WHICH TRIAL KNOWING
THE ONLY SUPPORT WILL BE
PARTISAN AND THERE FOR DOOMED TO
FAIL, WHILE BOASTING THAT YOU
KEEP DOING THAT FOREVER, ISN'T
THAT AN ABUSE OF POWER?
IT CERTAINLY AN ABUSE OF
AMERICANS PATIENTS,
INSTITUTIONS, TRUST, AND
COHESION'S, WHICH MAKES IT
ANOTHER MEDIA ASSISTED HOST.
IF YOU WANT TO FIND THE LIE,
JUST LOOK WHERE THE MEDIA .6
CAMERAS.
>> I HAVE THE THEORY THAT I
WOULD LIKE TO SHARE WITH YOU.
OKAY.
IT SO I BELIEVE THIS IMPEACHMENT
PROCESS SATISFIES THE MEDIA
WHILE HELPING TRUMP IN KEY
BATTLEGROUND STATES.
CORRECT?
SO WHAT IS THAT SOUND LIKE?
IT REMINDS ME OF CNN AND MSNBC
DOING NONSTOP MOCKING COVERAGE
OF TRUMP WHICH THE MEDIA AND THE
RATINGS ENJOYED AND IT GOT HIM
ELECTED.
ARE THEY TO STUPID --
'S MORNING JOE AND CNN JUST TOO
STUPID TO SEE THAT THEY ARE
REELECTING TRUMP?
>> I SEE WHAT DO YOU HAVE DONE
THERE.
SO THE --
ABSOLUTELY THE POLLING SHOWS
THAT TWO THINGS.
NATIONALLY REPUBLICANS AND
DEMOCRATS, NOTHING HAS CHANGED.
THE NUMBERS ARE THE EXACT SAME
AS THEY WERE NOT EVEN JUST THREE
MONTHS AGO BUT THREE YEARS AGO
WHEN THE PRESIDENT WAS ELECTED
AND THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO
DISAPPROVE OF THE PRESIDENT IS
AT 53% AND THAT WAS --
WHAT DID HILLARY CLINTON GET IN
THE POPULAR VOTE?
ABOUT THE NUMBER.
NOTHING HAS BEEN PERSUASIVE ON
EITHER SIDE.
BOTH SIDES ARE COMPLETELY LOCKED
IN AND STOPPED IN ONE PLACE AND
THAT IS IN THE KEY BATTLEGROUND
STATES.
OF MICHIGAN, WISCONSIN,
PENNSYLVANIA, AND OF THOSE THREE
STATES, IMPEACHMENT HAS
ABSOLUTELY HURT THE DEMOCRATS AD
IT HAS HELPED PRESIDENT TRUMP.
IT PRESIDENT TRUMP OR TOULOUSE
NEXT NOVEMBER NOVEMBER, IT WILL
NOT BE BECAUSE OF IMPEACHMENT.
IF THAT WILL ABSENTLY NOT BE THE
CASE.
ALSO IT WAS JUST ANNOUNCED THAT
THE HOUSE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE IS
GOING TO MOVE SO QUICKLY THAT
TOMORROW NIGHT AT 7:00 P.M. IS
WHEN THEY ARE TO THE MARKUP.
WHO SAYS CONGRESS CAN'T MOVE
QUICKLY?
I THINK THE REASON THEY WANT TO
DO THAT IS BECAUSE THEY WANT TO
RIP THE BANDIT OFTEN GET THIS
OVER WITH BECAUSE THEY KNOW
POLITICALLY WHILE IT WAS
IMPORTANT FOR THEIR FACE,
THEY NEED TO MOVE ON SO THEY CAN
TRY TO ARGUE ON THE MERIT GOING
INTO NOVEMBER.
>> Juan: DON'T TELL
ANDREW JOHNSON.
I THINK HE WAS IMPEACHED IN
THREE DAYS.
I WILL SAY THIS ABOUT THE
NUMBERS THAT DANA WAS SETTING
ACCURATELY, I DO THINK THAT IF
YOU LOOK AT THE NUMBERS AND
ALMOST HALF THE COUNTRY FAVORING
IMPEACHMENT OR REMOVAL, THAT'S
UNPRECEDENTED.
I GO BACK TO BILL CLINTON AND IT
WAS ONLY LIKE 29 AT THE MAX.
I THINK THE MEDIA IS ON BOTH
SIDES OF THIS AND I THINK THERE
HAS BEEN CONSIDERED IN MEDIA AND
I DON'T KNOW.
WHATEVER.
THERE'S ALL KINDS OF MEDIA WHERE
PEOPLE WANT TO SIMPLY HAVE THEIR
PRE-EXISTING OPINIONS AFFIRMED
BUT I WILL SAY THAT TO MY MIND
WHEN YOU LOOK AT AN ALLEGATION
LIKE BRIBERY AND YOU SAY I
DIDN'T SEE IT, I DON'T SEE THE
BRIBERY, I SEE THIS BIG BUCKET,
I WOULD SAY ONE, I GUESS IT
WASN'T A FISHING EXPEDITION, IT
WAS DONE IN GOOD FAITH AND THIS
IS WHAT THEY THINK, OR TWO, WHEN
YOU LOOK AT ABUSE OF POWER,
BRIBERY WOULD BE INCLUDED IN
SUCH A CHARGE WITH THE SO-CALLED
QUID PRO QUO ALLEGATION.
>> YOUR RIGHT PRAYER THE BRIBERY
JUST KIND OF WENT AWAY.
WE HAVE A BRIBERY MONTAGE THAT
WE CAN THROW AT THIS POINT THAT
MAKES THIS LOOK INCREDIBLY
SYMPATHETIC?
BECAUSE THERE WAS A LOT OF
EVIDENCE OF BRIBERY.
A SUBSTANTIAL AMOUNT OF EVIDENCE
ON THE ABUSE OF POWER IN THE
QUESTION OF BRIBERY.
>> DID THE PRESIDENT'S DEMANDS
ON UKRAINE CONSTANT BRIBERY?
>> BRIBERY OR ACTS OF OMISSION
AND IN THIS CASE, IT IS CLEARLY
ONE OF THOSE.
>> TREASON, BRIBERY, HIGH CRIMES
AND MISDEMEANORS.
IT >> Greg: WHAT HAPPENED TO
THE BRIBERY?
>> Juan: I THINK IT'S IN THAT
BUCKET I WAS TALKING ABOUT.
>> Greg: I THINK THE DEMS ARE
NOT SWIMMING IN THAT BUCKET.
>> Juan: I THINK THEY WERE
ACTUALLY ACTING IN GOOD FAITH,
NOT A FISHING EXPEDITION.
I WILL SAY THAT I CAN'T BELIEVE
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT LEFT-WING
MEDIA AND RIGHT WING MEDIA AND
HOW THIS REPORT GETS
INTERPRETED.
YOU KNOW, ALL OF THIS, EVEN WHAT
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT HERE, WHAT
ABOUT THE FACT THAT IT'S TRUMP'S
PEOPLE THESE CHARGES FROM
SILENCE TO TAYLOR TO --
>> Greg: LET ME GET JESSE IN
HAMPSHIRE JESSE, THE FIRST
IMPEACHMENT PROBABLY IN HISTORY
BASED ON EMOTIONAL TRAUMA PAID
US BEFORE THE TWO ARTICLES
REALLY ARE WE HATE YOU AND WE
CAN BE YOU, NOT ANYTHING NEW HER
CAN BE YOU, NOT ANYTHING NEW HE.
FIRST YOU HAD NO INCLUSION AND
THEN THERE WAS NO EXTORTION AND
NO BRIBERY, THEY ARE JUST
SETTLING ON THINGS.
EVERY PRESIDENT TELLS CONGRESS
THEY WILL SEE YOU IN COURT.
YOU CAN'T IMPEACH SOMEONE FOR
SAYING WHAT A JUDGE DECIDE.
THEN THE OTHER ONE, ABUSE OF
POWER, BY THAT STANDARD, EVERY
SINGLE PRESIDENT COULD HAVE BEEN
IMPEACHED BY THE VERY LOW
STANDARD.
THEY TRY TO RUSH THIS THING, THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE SAW IT WAS
FLIMSY AND THEN THEY LOST
INTEREST IN IT AND NOW EVERYONE
IS JUST TALKING ABOUT FOOTBALL
AND THE IRISHMAN.
THIS IS WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN.
TEN OF THESE DEMOCRATS IN TRUMPS
DISTRICTS NOW IN THE HOUSE, THEY
WANT A CENTER.
THEY DON'T EVEN WANT TO VOTE ON
IMPEACHMENT HERE THEY ARE
NERVOUS AND LIKE YOU SAID, YOU
ARE RIGHT.
TRUMP WAS LOSING TO THESE THREE
DEMOCRATIC CONTENDERS IN THESE
BATTLEGROUND STATES A MONTH AGO
AND NOW HE'S BEATING THEM ALL BY
A LOT AND HE HAS HAD A GREAT
YEAR IN 2019.
HE KILLED BAGHDADI, BLOCKBUSTER
JOB NUMBERS, I MEAN, ANY EXPOSED
DEEP STATE WHICH WE HAVEN'T EVEN
GOT INTO SO IT'S NOT A GOOD
YEAR.
>> Greg: I ALWAYS GO TO
WIKIPEDIA TO LOOK AT THE PLOT
SUMMARY BECAUSE I DON'T LIKE
DESCRIBING.
THIS IS --
I FEEL LIKE WE ALREADY KNEW THE
PLOT AND WE ARE LOOKING AT THIS
THING UNFOLD THAT WE ALREADY
KNOW WHERE IT'S GOING TO GO
WHICH IS NOWHERE.
>> Emily: THIS IS TRUE AND I
HEAR WHAT DO YOU ARE SAYING
WHICH IS THAT YOU ARE SAYING
IT'S INCLUDED IN THIS BUT I
THINK THAT'S WHAT IS DIFFICULT
FOR THE AVERAGE CITIZEN TO WRAP
THEIR BRAIN AROUND.
IT'S THE FACT THAT THIS RIDING
IS VERY AMORPHOUS.
IT IS AMBIGUOUS.
WHAT DOES THIS MEAN?
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS DEMONSTRATED
HE WILL REMAIN A THREAT TO
NATIONAL SECURITY.
I AM USED TO A STRATEGY THAT
PICKS ELEMENTS OF A CRIME AND
THAT PRESENTS TO A JURY HERE ARE
THE ELEMENTS OF THIS CRIME AND
HERE'S THE CODE THAT IS THE LAW
AND HERE IS THERE FOR WHY THIS
DEFENDANT COMMITTED A CRIME.
WHAT WE HAVE HERE IS LITERALLY A
THESIS AND I THINK WAS DIFFICULT
TO STOMACH ABOUT IT IS THAT
WE'VE BEEN HEARING MESSAGING
FROM THE LEFT THIS ENTIRE TIME
INCLUDING QUOTES LIKE
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS A CRIMINAL
AND WITH THAT WORD SPECIFICALLY,
BRIBERY.
THAT MAGICALLY DISAPPEARED AND
THESE ACCOUNTS WOULD NOT BE
MUTUALLY EXCLUSIVE?
THERE ARE SEVERAL MEANINGS WHY
ISN'T THERE MORE?
IF THERE WAS THAT INTENT ON
CATCHING SOMEONE WHO WAS ABUSING
POWER, WHY WOULDN'T THEY TRY
FROM A TO Z AND HOPING ONE WOULD
STICK BECAUSE JUST ONE IS ENOUGH
TO REMOVE HIM FROM POWER?
IT'S NOT PERSUASIVE.
>> Greg: THESE ARE PEOPLE
SAYING WHAT IT IS.
THEY DON'T KNOW WHAT COULD
HAPPEN SO THEY SAY WHAT IF THIS
COULD HAPPEN IN THE FUTURE GRID
THEY ARE TRYING TO PROSECUTE HIM
FOR A FUTURE CRIMES.
IT'S JUST LIKE MINORITY REPORT,
THAT GREAT MOVIE WITH TOM CRUIS
TOM CRUISE.